Just me and he's about three and a half years younger.
Oh,
so what are you doing personally?
Ah,
well,
you know,
most of the time I'm in the lab and try to run a bunch of companies to make
these drugs,
that reality.
Uh,
but daily I try to keep her healthy weight.
I do intermittent fasting,
which is pretty easy because I'm so busy.
I forget to eat.
How many hours do you give yourself every night?
Uh,
well I suffer from a late night snacking,
but I try to skip breakfast and,
and even skip lunch if I'm busy.
So I'm a night eater.
Um,
but that seemed to be good cause a study came out about a couple of weeks ago,
at least in mice that it's not what you eat,
it's when you eat.
That's most important for longevity really.
And when,
when being,
when like what's it cost?
It doesn't actually matter if you eat a lot in the morning or a lot at night.
I like nighttime eating,
but you need a period during the day at least if you're a mouse,
probably if you're a human where you're hungry.
And that puts your body in a defensive mode.
And this,
these are the things that we've been studying in my life for the last 20 years.
What are the processes that diet and exercise do for us?
They keep us healthy.
And why does calorie restriction and intermittent fasting make animals live so
much longer?
And we think we've figured out a large part of how that works.
And now we're mimicking that with molecules.
Um,
is the,
is the idea that you can mimic it with molecules and it be as effective as
intermittent fasting?
I think the molecules will be better.
Um,
and not only that,
when we add them onto a healthy diet and exercise in the animals,
they do even better.
It's like a supercharged mouse.
Now when you add them on to the mice,
do you also add them on with intermittent fasting and is there an additional
benefit?
Uh,
we do.
We do one of the first molecules that infants,
molecules that we are known for is resveratrol from red wine.
That molecule discovered it in my thirties at least,
linked to aging.
What we showed was that if you give it to a fat mouse,
there is healthy as a thin mouse.
Uh,
they live just as long.
They can get heart disease and all of the other bad stuff.
Then what we did was interesting.
We gave it to the mice either every day in their food or let them skip a meal
every day so that they were fed every other day.
And that combination of his Vertel plus every other day feeding,
we had the longest lifespan we'd ever seen.
And it was so it was additive.
Same with exercise.
If we give our latest molecule called airmen,
uh,
to a mouse and we exercise it,
it'll run even further than it could with either of those alone.
So it's not an excuse to sit around and just eat chips and watch TV.
It augments a healthy lifestyle.
Get you further than what you could get naturally.
So in any,
are you seeing a benefit in addition?
So it was the idea to compound all those things together.
Exactly.
Right.
So you asked about myself.
So I do,
I eat healthy,
I try to skip meals.
Uh,
I also take supplements.
Um,
and in fact,
most of my colleagues are in the field of aging or anti aging as people call it
a,
so I take enemen every morning.
What is an m?
N?
Good question.
So let me take a quick step back.
Sure.
Uh,
so about 20 years ago,
ah,
Lenny Guarente and a team of us at MIT discovered a set of genes that controls
aging in yeast cells,
just brews east what you find in beer and bread.
And those genes are called Sir tunes.
And there are seven of them in our bodies,
five and yeast.
And what they do is they protect all organisms on the planet,
plants,
bacteria,
humans from deterioration and disease.
They're like the Pentagon.
They sense when we're hungry,
since when we're exercising and they send out the troops to defend us.
So when you,
when you put more of these genes into a yeast cell or a mouse,
they'll live longer between five to 20% longer.
And so we think that these genes are responsible for the effects of dieting and
exercise,
which is great.
Which what that means is we can now mimic that with molecules.
So Anna men is one of those molecules.
So he's virtual that you can think of her as virtual as the accelerator pedal
for the Sirtuin genes.
And the enemy is the,
is the fuel and without fuel rich virtual event works or Nmn is the gas in the
car?
I've heard of resveratrol but is NMN a new molecules?
Is commercially available?
Are some people who started selling it on the Internet?
Um,
fucking eight related to uh,
NR,
which is sold by a bunch of companies and our,
yeah,
nicotinamide riboside is a supplement that raises the levels of a molecule
called Nad feel like I should make a shopping list so they get a pen.
So what,
what are you writing that down to that?
So the Sirtuin okay,
get this.
Social Tunes Need Nad to work without them.
They're at work.
In fact,
if you don't have nad in your body,
you'd be dead in about 30 seconds.
It's a really important molecule.
But as we get older,
we lose nad.
So by the time you're 50,
like I almost am,
you have that half levels of once or you had when you're 20,
so that's not good.
And these are two ones.
They don't protect the body without high levels of Nad.
So what Nmn does,
and this other molecule called NR,
which both you can get on the Internet,
they boost the body's levels of Nad backup to youthful levels again.
And if we give them to mice,
these molecules,
team to mice or even to worms or yeast,
they live longer and they super healthy.
Now,
what level or how many milligrams are you taking of these things?
Uh,
so yeah,
and a man is,
is um,
something I get from,
for myself,
I'm not selling anything.
So I take a gram of any men in the morning based on clinical trials has been
shown that that will raise nad with or without food.
Um,
I take a little bit of yogurt that I make myself at home just to see me.
Uh,
you have been doing this for awhile.
and uh,
I only start doing stuff when I say working animals first.
So take,
take the yogurt mix in some are virtual,
virtual is great,
but it's really in solubles like brick dust.
So in the yoga will dissolve.
Take another half a gram of her is virtual and how much a half a gram.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's a powder.
I have a few kilos leftover from clinical trials in my basement.
Uh,
so yeah,
that,
that's going to last me a few decades.
Uh,
and then I also take at nights and Metformin,
which is probably the most radical thing that I take,
which is a prescribable drug for diabetes.
Net Foreman met met m m e t and prescribable drug.
So you but you don't have diabetes?
I do not.
But you take it for,
for preventing cancer,
heart disease,
Alzheimer's and aging met for I can you spell it?
M e t f o r m.
I.
N.
And so out of studies of 10,000 people and more,
it's been shown that people who take metformin,
er,
even if they have diabetes,
are protected against other diseases of aging.
Even frailty.
And so most scientists have you asked them,
in my field,
we'll say you metformin is likely to extend your lifespan.
It's just that the FDA doesn't let you have it for aging because aging isn't a
disease yet.
So do you have to get diabetes to get it or do you have to get a sneaky doctor?
Well,
I wouldn't call a sneaky doctor,
but the doctor typically has to be convinced because they don't keep up with the
literature and it's off label.
Okay.
All right.
And how much should you take of that?
Uh,
I take a gram of that as well,
which is about a,
a low dose as some diabetics type two grams.
So it's not crazy amounts.
Is there any side effects?
Well,
the good news is that it's extremely rare that you get sick from any of these
molecules.
Um,
in millions of patients around the world.
Nobody's getting sick.
The worst you'll have as far as I can tell is a stomach upset.
And I get that,
which is actually helpful if I'm hungry or I lose my appetite.
But,
uh,
I think the downside is extremely low and that the upside is,
you know,
anything's better than what's coming and what is the mechanism that metformin is
operating.
Okay.
So that,
so this is the great thing is that over the last 20 years,
we have figured out,
we scientists have figured out that there are universal regulators of aging from
yeast to worms to mice and in humans.
And there were three main pathways that we figured out,
respond to what we eat,
how we exercise.
And one of them is called a m p k a,
and this is,
uh,
a target metformin.
And so I'm active.
When I take Metformin,
I'm activating my amp K,
which we'll send out the troops.
Uh,
the Sir two ones I've mentioned,
that's the second of the pathways.
And so I take enemen and reserve tool for that.
And then third one is called Mtor,
which is a pathway in the body that responds to how many amino acids,
how much meat you're eating,
uh,
and it will also protect the body if you tweak it just the right way.
And there's only,
besides eating low amounts of protein,
the only way to,
to effect that pathways with a drug called Rapamycin,
which is,
which is a little dangerous to try and is,
is used for a immunosuppressants.
So it's not something that I would recommend and I don't take it.
Wow.
So this is your daily routine along with what would kind of like died do you
follow?
Well,
I,
I try to not eat too much.
It's pretty easy to overeat.
So I try to skip one or two meals a day.
Um,
I avoid sugars and carbs.
I try to run once a week.
I do work outs on the weekend.
Like you,
I,
I love Saunas.
I like to put my body in some temperature,
stress,
all your hate.
And then I jump in a cold bath back and forth that,
that works well for yeast.
We can do that in lab and I,
they live 30% longer.
So,
uh,
there's all that.
Um,
do you have generally,
generally I eat normally.
Do you ever try going from Sauna to cryotherapy?
Uh,
no.
I haven't tried actual cryotherapy.
Just a that you haven't done it a raw Nah,
you won't do it today.
Sure.
Have you got one?
Yeah.
We'll take you,
take you down the street.
There's a great one because it's,
um,
there's different kinds and some of them are from the neck down where they're
using liquid nitrogen.
The other ones,
they actually freeze the air.
So when they're,
they're using the nitrogen to freeze the air and they're pumping in air that's
240 degrees below zero.
And you're,
you know,
you're going to do about two minutes.
I do three because I do it all the time,
but uh,
it's awesome.
I do three and then I take 10 minutes off and then I go back in for another
three.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
And what you're doing to your body when you do that,
we think is to activate these longevity pathways like this or two ones.
Yeah.
And uh,
and that's really the trick is to activate your body's defenses against aging.
Uh,
I mean,
the old theories about aging,
you've got to throw them out.
Most people at parties will tell you,
oh,
antioxidants,
free radicals,
DNA damage or mutations.
That is all for the most part,
incorrect that antioxidants cause DNA damage.
Now that's true that it repairs DNA damage.
Well,
antioxidants have been a rather big failure in the aging field,
but resveratrol is an antioxidant.
Correct?
Uh,
it's a mild antioxidant,
but it doesn't work by being an intox.
Oh,
what does it work?
What does the pathway,
it steps on the accelerator pedal of the Sirtuin enzymes.
And so it's directly controlling the body's defenses against aging.
So as we discussed it,
or as people discussed it as an anti oxidant there,
it was just a mom,
a mild form of antibiotics and an accident,
but it didn't so much more.
Right.
And we know this because if you create a yeast cell or a worm or a mouse,
and then you knock out the gene for the Sirtuin,
now raise Vertel doesn't help the animal anymore.
That's interesting because when people talk about wine,
that's the one thing they say.
There was very Charles and antioxidants.
Really good for you.
Yeah.
This is one of those urban myths that never goes away and still fuels a billion
dollar industry.
But what we're finding is that the molecules in plants like resveratrol,
first of all,
we think that produced by plants because the plants are benefiting from the
stress.
Uh,
we call it hormesis.
A little bit of stress is good for you.
What doesn't kill you,
makes you stronger kind of thing.
And hormesis was discovered,
uh,
about 60,
70 years ago when people were spraying herbicides on plants and a little bit of
urbicide actually made them stronger.
And we think that these molecules in plants are similar,
that they make the plant stronger during times of stress.
So if you stress a grape that's for wine making,
you get great wine,
but you also get a lot of virtual.
And so when we ingest that resveratrol from the clients,
we get the same health benefits because the plants are activating their
serotonin pathways and we have the [inaudible] tunes and they activate us as
well.
Ah,
interesting.
Interesting.
So low
carb,
low sugar,
um,
any specific type of protein?
Do you limit your amount of protein?
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
I enjoy eating mammals just as much as anybody,
but,
um,
I try to avoid them.
Um,
for the main,
well,
two main reasons.
One is that,
uh,
there's this TMAO molecule that seems to cause heart disease.
Tmao yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
and how's it linked heart disease?
these epidemiology studies,
I forget,
but I do recall that the study was able to give the Tmao to animals and they
developed heart disease.
So it's somehow causing it,
I forget exactly how it might be damaging the genome.
That's my recollection with omnivores or predators.
Uh,
I think as red meat is the culprit,
right?
So are they giving this to rats?
Are the given us too?
It was a mouse study again,
so I mean,
my might be different from humans of course.
Uh,
but the other problem with,
with meat in general,
from,
from animals is that there's a lot of minnows in there and it's easy to eat a
lot of meat.
And so if you have high levels of immuno acids,
it will activate this mtor pathway,
one of those three on Jevity pathways.
And you don't want that.
You don't want that.
You don't want that cause him Tor has evolved to cents times of adversity and
stress and hunger.
So why do people see a performance benefit when they consume branch chain amino
acids?
A really good question.
So in the short run,
just like taking testosterone,
it will give you performance benefits,
but we think in the long run,
it'll actually come back to bite you.
So how will blend branch chain amino acids come back to bite you?
So branch chain amino acids will activate this mtor pathway.
Um,
and
when we do that in animals,
we actually,
we reduced their lifespan.
So it's the opposite.
You want to keep those levels low.
That's interesting that that seems,
I mean,
for a dummy like me,
it seems counterintuitive because what's making you perform better?
Currently you would see,
you would think,
especially something like amino acids and natural part of the human body,
you would think that that would be beneficial.
You're adding to your body something that it needs.
Yeah,
you would.
But,
but what you should consider is that it's a trade off.
There's a theory that probably correct.
Uh,
it's the,
uh,
some Tom Kirkwood's terror theory called the disposable Soma.
And our bodies want to do one of two things.
Either want to grow really fast and reproduce fast,
build up a lot of muscle cells,
divide that's great.
In the short run,
you know,
you'd be fertile,
you can run.
But actually that it's at the expense of hunkering down and building a long
lasting body.
It's a trade off over time.
And so animals that grow fast and reproduce fast like a mouse,
we'll only have a short lifespan,
whereas a whale that grows slowly and reproduce it slowly will live a long time.
Interesting.
So the idea is you're,
you're limiting your calories,
you're limiting your carbohydrates,
you're limiting your protein,
you're limiting your amino acids,
but you're ramping up and all these beneficial molecules,
right.
These,
these pathways that have evolved since the beginning of life to make us live
longer during adversity so he can thrive when times come back that he could do
you take into consideration quality of life versus length of life?
Like is there a,
uh,
like a sweet spot?
Yeah,
that,
well,
it's hard to ask the mice how they feel,
but they,
uh,
we do test them and we do frailty studies and we can see that they got better
memory and they can run further and a treadmill.
Um,
they're stronger.
Those kinds of things they see better.
And,
uh,
you know,
we think that that probably means they're happier as well.